my name is stephanie and i'm a program
manager on the mic on the microsoft edge
developer experiences team um you can
find me across social media
at sea otta
and today i'm going to talk about html
form controls
and why am i here to talk about html
form controls
well i stumbled across this date picker
while i was attempting to book my day
two covid test for this trip
and i thought oh this will be a great
example of a current custom control that
provides a completely different
experience compared to the native one
and imagine my surprise when i went to
the mdn docs and this was actually the
native date picker
and imagine my shock of this realization
that i actually haven't encountered a
native date picker on a website in so
long that i didn't know that this was
the experience
i've been encountering custom date
pickers probably every time for
well as long as i can remember
but this is a perfect example of the
issue and the pain points that i'm going
to talk about today with native form
controls
and the crux of these things is that
native controls are neither as
customizable or extensible as modern
developers need them to be
which leads to them recreating their
controls from scratch and abandoning
native controls despite all of the
advantages that the browser engine bakes
in for developers
and so today i'm going to give a brief
overview of the past of html controls
sort of how we got to where we are today
talk about the current problems
with native controls and then how we are
proposing solving these pain points in
standards groups and eventually in
browsers
so first we need to go back to 1995
when html 2.0 became the first
specification that was ratified by the
w3c
and with that specification came our
first set of standardized form controls
but the specification didn't standardize
form parts or how they were built
it standardized the method to enter data
into an html document and for that data
to be used to perform an action such as
logging into a website so it
standardized what the forms were
supposed to do but not how they were
built
and so we have our spec and we have some
standardized html building blocks to
build websites
but we're still missing something this
is early days of the web
we're lacking a standardized styling
language
so css wasn't supported by the html
standard until html 3.20 in 1997 but it
wasn't even actually until 1999
that browsers really embraced and
supported css with the 4.01
specification
so that's four years later so if we go
back to 1995 we have form controls
but we have no styling language to style
them so browsers had to rely on the
operating systems to render and style
those form controls and that led to a
dependency on the operating system but
this was it's this is not how it's done
today so it has evolved since then
but even
later on with early versions of css
there were parts of form controls that
css just couldn't access
on the other side of this was that
browser vendors were also extremely
reluctant to make controls uh more
styleable because they were a reflection
of the operating system's visual
appearance and so the idea that
developers would want or need to make
form controls look different or
customize them wasn't really a concept
and so when they finally accepted that
developers wanted this
we were given the appearance property
but it only controlled the system level
styling and developers didn't actually
use appearance for its intended purpose
and on top of that it wasn't actually
implemented as designed by browsers and
that led to lots of partial support and
interoperability issues
especially in the early 2000s when
internet explorer was the dominant
browser
it didn't even support it so it wouldn't
even
work in ie
and so if we jump 26 years so if we jump
to now that's 26 years of the web
evolving has led us to the state that
we're in now
and the debt the web has definitely
improved since then but in those 26
years we haven't really done much to
make native form controls easier to work
with
even though there have been some
improvements and we've even gone on to
add some new form controls
so if we look at the state of styling
current controls today i've got them
bucketed out into three categories and
most of the controls that we really want
more control over styling are in our
third bucket which i call the good night
and good luck bucket because of how hard
it is to style these if you can even
style them at all
and then on top of that we have all
these browser inconsistencies in how
they render and so as a web designer
before i knew about the web platform it
was really really hard to explain to my
clients why the form controls look
differently in different browsers and
that was so frustrating and that again
boils down to that issue that i
discussed initially that form controls
and their parts
were not standardized so browser
engineers built and then styled them
differently and this is just looking at
a couple of the top browsers today
and so on top of poor css access to
style controls
and then browser inconsistencies we
can't actually extend the functionality
of a control
i love this tweet from scottgel you have
one problem you want icons and your
select menu options you decide to make a
custom select menu you now have at least
75 problems
and that's because when you rebuild a
control from scratch instead of using
the native control you don't get all of
the good stuff that's baked in like
accessibility and security
by the browser and so as a developer you
have to add all that back in and then
you have to test it to ensure that you
did it correctly
that's a lot of time and that's a bad
developer experience but it's necessary
when you can't extend your controls the
way you need to
a great example of this is the video
element where the developer either gets
all of the controls
or none of them just by adding or
removing the controls attribute
and when we want our html controls to
look like this
or this
it's no wonder developers have just
perverted to building forms from scratch
every single time
and so on the browser side
we decided to step back and ask some
questions because we wanted to make sure
that this was an area that we should go
invest in we knew it was a pain point
but were better native form control
something that developers really really
wanted
and the answer was overwhelmingly yes
so my colleague greg whitworth who is
now at salesforce um and ran an initial
survey on twitter
to really start to dive deep into this
space so he had a variety of respondents
from different roles and varying degrees
of experience with working on the web
and one of the questions asked was which
forum control did respondents recreate
the most and these were the top ten
select came in at first at 10.7
check box
at 10.2
and then date at 9.5 percent
and then he wanted to know why
why were the why were developers
rebuilding controls from scratch
and over a third said it was because
they couldn't change the appearance
sufficiently
another third just wanted to add
functionality so they wanted to extend
their control
and just under a third said because of
browser inconsistencies which we can
probably assume has to do with
appearance
and so if we lump that in with the first
group of respondents who said it was
because they couldn't change the
appearance sufficiently that's
two-thirds of developers spending all of
this time recreating controls just for
appearance
and then greg shared an amended survey
with js configu attendees in 2019 and he
asked two additional questions he asked
which forum control gives you the most
frustration
and why
and select clearly stole the show here
with nearly 50 percent of respondents
saying select
and date was the next closest one at
17.3 percent
and then he asked why and these were
some of the verbatims that he got
select requires hacky tricks
can't style option elements at all to
the extent we need to
but the amount of work it takes to
implement an accessible alternative with
complete feature parity
is massive and i can just feel the pain
oozing out of this response and so this
prompted me to ask my own question of
developers i wanted to know how painful
is it
and so i did my own research and went to
twitter and i asked developer and
front-end designers to please fill in
the blank
i would rather blank than attempt to
style a native select element
and y'all really hate select
a lot
i think i got over 250 responses to this
tweet and i'll just highlight some of my
favorites
so
i would rather call each person
attempting to use the form and ask them
what option they would like
i'd rather build the entire site and
flash
support ie6
chew on glass
and this has been my favorite
maybe a bit melodramatic but heat up a
rust fueled fork with a few tines
snapped off and broken and then with
both arms thrust it into my inner thigh
then attempt to style a native select
menu
so clearly
we have an issue this is clearly a pain
point for developers
so let's talk about the future and
what's to come and also what's been in
progress because so there's been some
stuff in progress since i first started
giving this talk
and i'm excited to share that it's shiny
and exciting
and so the first bit of work that i'm
going to talk about is specific to
chromium so
edge has been leading the controls work
and we've been collaborating closely
with chrome to make updates to the
native controls in the chromium project
and so our first focus was improving the
style of native controls in chromium and
then accessibility improvements so we
were we brought some of that
accessibility work that we had in the
html edge html engine over into chromium
when we made that switch
and so with the new styles the team
landed on a much more modern and neutral
look that we hope lessens the time spent
on recreating form controls purely for
styling purposes
while we work on the standards work to
bring better control styling to browsers
or at least to the chromium browser
but that's not all we've done to the
native controls in chromium so
as of june this year i'm excited to
share dark mode for form controls in
chromium
and so when a web developer expresses
support for dark mode and the user has
this mode enabled our user agent style
sheet will auto darken form controls out
of the box
and so like normal styles that are added
by a web developer or user will override
the user agent style so if you've made
your text input background bright yellow
you'll need to update that color
yourself in dark mode using the prefers
color scheme media query
but to render all document form controls
in dark mode a meta tag declaration is
needed to let the browser know which
color modes the website supports so our
declaration here tells the browser that
it's safe to render controls as light or
dark
and this is available in microsoft edge
on the desktop in version 87.
um chrome on android for version 91 and
future versions of microsoft edge for
android
and you can go to aka dot ms whack dark
dash controls for more information on
how to implement that
and then next i want to talk about html
because html isn't done it is a living
language
so
we're also looking at new native
components
for html and a lot of these proposals
are coming out of the research being
done
and the work that has started with
rebuilding the select element
and so while looking at how we wanted to
build a new version of select
the team identified a need for a
universal pop-up element
and this proposal this proposed pop-up
element is a transient user interface
and that's displayed on top of all other
web ui and so this would be things like
action menus form element suggestions
content pickers and teaching ui
additionally the key differentiator for
a pop-up element from other
aesthetically similar elements is
something that we're calling light
dismissed behavior
and so light dismissed behavior means
that the pop-up will automatically be
hidden when one of three things happens
so the user hits the escape key
the layout of the pop-up or its anchor
element is changed or focus moves
outside of the pop-up and its anchor
element if applicable and a generalized
definition of light dismiss
is currently being discussed in the open
ui working group which i will talk about
a little bit later
and so elements that don't have light
dismissed behavior would be things like
alerts toasts custom tool tips and other
persistent pop-over ui
so if we look at our basic example here
for pop-up we have a button element and
a pop-up element and to tie the button
to the pop-up we have our button id
equals menu button and we'd use an
anchor attribute and set that value to
the button id of menu button
and currently pop-up menus are not
visible until show is called by the
author so we do need some script here
for more information on pop-up you can
go to aka dot ms whack pop-up dash
explainer and there's quite a bit more
technical details in that explainer
and then there's some other fun work
that's been going on in the open ui
working group so
we have a demo of what tabs could
possibly look like
in the browser and so this is all
experimental
and would require proposing quite a few
new elements to get this to work
but this is getting the work started to
figure out if this would meet developers
needs
and so you can go check out that tabs
demo at aka dot ms whack tabs dash demo
the other thing that we're looking at is
something called anchored positioning
and so this is a proposal that allows
the anchoring or pinning of top layer ui
like the pop-up
we see here to a point on another
element and so how the top player ui is
positioned with respect to its anchor
element is further influenced or
constrained by the edges of the layout
viewport
so in our example here we have a menu
whose top left point is anchored to the
bottom left point on a menu button and
when there's insufficient space in the
viewport below the button um the pop-up
menu would be rendered above the menu
button instead
and again you can check out more
information on
anchored positioning at aka dot ms wack
anchor dash pause
and now let's talk about
the thing that i'm most excited about so
let's talk about fixing the current
problems with controls and styling and
extending them
so
last year in august 2020 an explainer
with the proposed solutions for how we
want to approach
enabling customization of controls ui
was released
by chrome edge and the open ui working
group
the proposal for form controls is using
the mvc design pattern where the form
control is made up of three distinct
parts so a model a view and a controller
and the goals that this proposal set out
to accomplish revolve around enabling as
much customization as possible while
reducing the overhead for the developer
and so we're proposing three different
solutions that offer a range of
flexibility in customization depending
on what the developer wants
so let's just dive into the first
solution so again in that brief history
of controls that i talked about
the root of the issue is that form
controls and their parts aren't
standardized and so they're not
reachable by developers
open ui is the initiative under the ycg
which is the web incubator community
group to standardize form controls and
components
and the open ui team which is open to
anyone who would like to participate
is focused on researching and
documenting design systems and
frameworks that are already out there
today they're identifying patterns and
naming in use cases and then using those
patterns to establish cow paths for
standards and eventually browsers
so because select was the biggest pain
point for developers
it's been the first form that open ui
started to research
there's an editor's draft proposal for
select on the open ui website if you
want to go check that out lots of
different details use cases
references to some of the frameworks
that that we
referenced
and so when i talk about standardizing
control anatomy i'll use select as an
example of what that can look like
so we would define the anatomy of a
select as consisting of one button part
containing one selected value part
and one pop-up list box part
that contains zero to n option parts
and then we'd go on to define the
expected behavior of a select like what
happens when you click on it and so on
so this standardized anatomy will allow
the styling of made of parts using
pseudo classes and the part pseudo
element so a developer will be able to
change the color of a select button for
example in an interoperable manner
without replacing any of the html
so in our example here we have our css
class called styled select and we're
utilizing the part pseudo element to
target the button to change the
background color
and notice the html code here is just
the code of a select today so you
wouldn't have to rewrite any of the
actual form control we're just exposing
the parts of a select and giving
developers access to styling via pseudo
elements and classes
and then additionally other states will
also be standardized so for example the
open state for select
so that's our first proposed solution
our second proposal
enables more powerful customization of
controls and the content within them
with something called named slots
so a set of slot names will correspond
to each piece of the controls view that
a developer might want to replace with
their own content so in the case of
select we would have slot equals button
and slot equals list box
and that will indicate to the platform
that custom content will be slotted in
by the developer
and in addition developers would add
part equals button and part equals list
box which i'll go into briefly in a
moment about why that will be needed
but if you've ever wanted to add like a
country flag or some other visual
content into your list box for select
which is just the drop down this will
allow you to do that without rewriting
the whole control from scratch
slots also provide the flexibility to
customize only specific parts of a
control so let's take input type equals
range as an example
so a developer could provide a slot and
a part name for the move for the movable
thumb and the ui for the track would
automatically fall back to the default
provided by the platform
and there's actually quite a bit of work
that would need to be done so this is
sort of the the dream of what we would
like to see happen
and so you might be asking why do i have
to provide both a part and a slot name
so by adding part to your code this will
signal to the platform that it has code
to wire up to your control and that will
apply native event handlers where
applicable to handle user input which
means that developers can make ui tweaks
without having to write tons of
javascript or rewrite tons of code
additionally this will also apply the
correct accessibility semantics to your
controls as well so by adding part to
your code
you're just letting the platform do what
it was meant to do and applying those
things for you
just add your parts
and our third solution
is shadow dom replacement so currently
attach shadow this throws an exception
you can't call it on any form control
currently
and so we're proposing removing this
restriction when enabling customization
for a given control
and calling attached shadow will result
in the default user agent shadow dom
being swapped out with a new shadow
route that will be populated with
content provided by the developer
developers will still be required to
label the core parts of their shadow dom
using the part attribute otherwise the
shadow dom will not be rendered the
platform is not going to make an attempt
to guess at the correct behavior and
won't render an incomplete control
implementation and again just add your
parts and let the platform do what it
was meant to do for you
please go check out the explainer at aka
dot ms wet controls dash explainer there
are so many more technical details
that i don't have time to go into today
but i want to say we need you we need
your feedback and your opinions on this
work
and there are multiple ways that you can
do that so you can contribute to the
forum control investigations on open ui
again
anyone can join that
working group
tell browser vendors what you need from
your form controls whether it's new form
controls or certain functionality that
you expect a form control to have
be loud and let us know we do listen to
that
and then you can also provide feedback
on the explainers
those are all hosted on github so you
can go open an issue
and our team will look at those and
respond to those
you can also follow these folks so
nicole sullivan is the google chrome pm
working on this
greg whitworth is at salesforce and he
runs the open ui working group and i'm
stephanie i'm sea otta
and i am the microsoft edge pm on this
right now
because we are here to listen because
these improvements are ultimately for
you
thank you